Tumbleweeds!
Iconic, majestic, all tumbly!
If the USDA has their way, they’ll be going
the way of the dodo.
But how will we know that we’re in a ghost
town?
Hey folks, I’m Matt Lieberman filling in
for DNews.
Tumbleweeds are a firmly established part
of Americana.
The balls of Russian thistle dry over time
in the hot sun and are ripped from their roots
by wind, sending them tumbling helplessly
in whatever direction that nature deems appropriate.
This can be a huge problem for all of us non-tumbling
stay-putters, as tumbleweeds can grow to six
feet in diameter, and, when they finally come
to rest, can clog waterways and are difficult
to dispose of.
They’re more prickly than a porcupine before
his morning coffee, and busting up and burning
the big balls of bramble-like bother is a
timesuck that, quite frankly, no one has the
time for any longer.
Also, Tumbleweeds are some of the most cunningly
designed cultivators in nature, which is great!
Well, it’d be better if they dropped, say,
fruit or vegetable seeds as they bounce beholden
to the breeze, rather than more russian thistle
seeds, not to mention pests that basically
get a free bus ride cross-country, making
them that much harder to contend with.
These reasons are enough for the US Department
of Agriculture to take drastic steps, calling
for the eradication of Russian thistles on
American soil.
So, how are they going to do that?
If you’re imagining a team of specialists
running after fugitive tumbleweeds with pitchforks
and torches, you’re really creative, but
mistaken.
The USDA has developed viruses from two types
of dying tumbleweeds from Russia and Hungary,
and are currently testing the effects that
those viruses would have on our ecosystem
if used.
Under strict quarantine, scientists have exposed
the viruses to 64 and 89 types of plants,
respectively.
The results of those tests reveal that the
closer a plant is genetically to tumbleweeds,
the more it is harmed by these viruses.
Despite the potential damage, the USDA is
currently lobbying for permission to release
the viruses to curb the tumbleweed population
permanently.
So how do you feel about Tumbleweeds?
Should they be exterminated?
Let us know in the comments below.
I’m Matt Lieberman filling in for DNews.
You can find more of my videos over at Sourcefed.
Please like the video and subscribe to the
channel.
Thanks for watching.